salut les menthe à l'eau aujourd'hui je
tiens la caméra à la main oui c'est
comme ça a bougé un tout petit peu avant
de lancer la vidéo je voulais vous
expliquer pourquoi j'avais fait cette
vidéo c'est une vidéo qui est un petit
peu sur le développement personnel
puisque si on laisse aussi avec les
bases du mentalisme il s'avère que la
plupart du temps on a les ressources en
soi pour répondre à certaines questions
c'est à dire que si on a des ambitions
des buts des objectifs des rêves
on a nous même à l'intérieur de nous
tout le chemin qui est tracé on sait
lequel il faut prendre c'est juste qu'on
ne veut pas se l'avouer parce que cela
vous et ça voudrait dire si m et ça
c'est un petit peu le but de la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui salue les menthe à l'eau
aujourd'hui je suis avec julien de oui
tu savais pas que satan mais j'aime bien
je fais ce que je veux j'aimerais que tu
me dises une de tes ambitions ou anne
thérèse quelque chose que tu aimerais
réalisé dans ta vie ça peut être quelque
chose d'un peu ouf tu vois ça peut être
quelque chose de très basique ça peut
être gagné l'auto peu importe mais
qu'elle est vraiment ton ambition moteur
dans la vie un vivre vivre dans un pays
étranger né dans le barack sur la plage
tu vois voilà ce que j'ai écrit j'ai
écrit sous le soleil sous des cieux le
soleil du devoir avec des taux la france
est ton rêve
ok on va faire un petit exercice
ensemble donc tu vas tenir la porte et
quoi qu'il arrive tu ne la lâchera
jamais c'est très important
j'aime bien est ce que tu nous fais
confiance oui fabien vraiment tu peux me
faire confiance je vais te demander de
fermer les yeux tout le long de
l'expérience et de ne jamais lâcher la
porte
ok ton rêve c'est de vivre sous le
soleil avec une grosse baraque etc
et je trouve que c'est un chouette rêve
en soi maintenant est ce que tu pourrais
imaginer qu est ce qu il faudrait de
quoi tu aurais besoin pour réaliser ce
rêve
de quoi tu as besoin exactement je te
nommerai dillon du coup un peu d'argent
tout de même de l'argent maintenant que
c'est vrai tu as besoin d'argent pour ça
du coup pour gagner cet argent qu est ce
que tu pourrais mettre en place dans ta
vie qui te permettent d'accéder à
l'argent en fait à la somme dont on
aurait besoin pour faire ça nous parle
par exemple d'epargne ou d'autres choses
toi ce serait pour son héritage
l'héritage c'est vrai mais là c'est des
attentes hasardeuse qu'est ce que tu
pourrais mettre concrètement en classe
dès aujourd'hui pour ça allait je n'ai
pas regardé n'est pas bon mais pendant
huit ans et comme ça après avoir ouvert
pendant tout le match je regarde combien
tu pourrais m par mois deux côtés qui ne
touchent pas à ton rythme de vie actuel
d'un euro sans l'euro 1000 euros
je parle de 100 euros 200 euros est ce
qu'aujourd'hui tu mettes 200 euros par
mois pour ça mais non fabien nom est tu
vois c'est en vrai c'est quelque chose
que tu pourrais faire tu vois ou de la
même manière tu parles de production tu
pourrais très bien imaginer dans cette
production l'a déjà projeté un projet
duquel tu retires est une vraie sommes
tu vois quelque chose de défini vois ce
que je veux dire pour ce projet là et
peut-être que ce serait des bureaux en
fait que de réussir la plage ça serait
un petit peu fort bien tu vois comment
est-ce que tu as d'autres choses qui te
viennent de tous les possibles ou pas
non pas pour tout le monde pas pour le
muhr ok c'est intéressant parce que de
faire ça tu les yeux fermés pour vivre
ton rêve sous le soleil
tu viens de trouver des clés des choses
auxquelles tu aurais peut-être pas pensé
tu t'étais pas encore projeté
aujourd'hui tu sais concrètement quelles
actions tu pourrais mettre en place pour
atteindre ce rêve qui fait qu'avec
toutes ses clés tu atteindras de rêve
puisque tu peux ouvrir les yeux aux
dents tambour avant non non non non
juste d'ouvrir les yeux
ce que t'as jamais lâché la porte à la
différence de tout à l'heure c'est que
maintenant le rêve est accessible et que
tu as toutes les clés en face de toi et
tu n'as jamais lâcher cette porte et où
ils ont pu quoi tu en rêvais juste
derrière je t'offre cette carte là comme
ça tu te souviendras des clés pour la
mettre sur ton bureau tu sais que ton
objectif de vie tu pour elle qui pourra
l'atteindre avant tout cas c'est ce que
je te souhaite mais qu il faut bien ou
pas oui en fait c'est une expérience de
développement personnel associé au
mentalisme qui a mis en place un pote
que tu connais qui s'appelle julia
lowe's a reconnu julien loza c'est un
pote qu'au brésil c'est lui qui a mis ça
en place
on peut en faire un tour de mentalisme
qui est basé sur le thème d'alice au
pays des merveilles
mais cette version sur le développement
personnel est très intéressante on peut
faire beaucoup de choses avec ça si ça
vous intéresse je vais vous mettre un
lien
dans l'est dans le descriptif vers
julien et versa qui s'appelle alice est
une merveille je trouve que c'est un
petit bonheur ce truc
et pour l'avoir fait plusieurs fois sur
des gens comme toi là toi tu avais un
vrai vampire plus standard mais des fois
tu arrives à sortir des choses
auxquelles tu n'aurais jamais pensé
avant pour atteindre ce rêve tu vois
j'ai eu un mec qui voulait être une rock
star et tout en faisant l'exercice qu il
faut peut-être que je prenne des cours
de guitare quand est ce qu'il pourra le
faire dès demain ce que tu vas appelé
bah oui et depuis prend des cours de
guitare tu vois je trouve ça hyper
intéressant quand je vais pas renier dès
demain tu avais parlé dès demain
vraiment et si vous connaissez pas
julien et ben c'est étonnant ouais c'est
super étonnant et le terrain mais moi je
le connais très bien
julien vous payer 200 euros pour me voir
là mais toi tu es partout en même temps
ce mec là c'est un artiste et un
comédien c'est un très bon comédien avec
ce style de la t'imagines tu fais
beaucoup de choses derrière les caméras
devant la caméra et dans le bureau de
production aussi montée sur les trois
pôles en même temps tu as d'ailleurs il
a lancé une chaîne youtube
allez indéfinissable mais un lien vers
la vidéo vers le pilote de monster ça
c'était super drôle et chercher le
dedans ils jouent dedans et en plus il
ya un truc à savoir dans la vidéo fait
un petit peu comme ceux qui regardent
les films et bizarre là il ya un faux
raccords ya un faux raccords quelque
part trouvé le chômage pence
merci beaucoup si vous avez aimé ça si
vous voulez qu'on en parle on en parle
dans les commentaires de tout ce qu'on
peut faire avec cette application là si
vous voulez en savoir un petit peu plus
moi j'aime beaucoup ça
n'oubliez pas si vous voulez le sait un
petit pouce en l'air mais surtout de
vous abonner à la chaîne 7 ce côté-là et
rendez vous demain parce que le mental
boxe et une vidéo par jour pendant un an
à la main ciao
je joue mon spectacle en entier le 23
septembre à la garenne colombes c'est la
date la plus proche de paris si jamais
vous voulez venir sinon il ya toutes les
dates de tournée sur mon site
on se voit sous le soleil du coup moins
ciblé saleh
il